LOGAN ROY:
Let's finish the fucking job
before this breaks.
Shiv, let's get you out here.
-I need your help on the optics.
-No.
I am not flying out to Argestes
to be the face of this.
Then what the fuck are you doing
on the phone, Siobhan?
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This episode is set
in Argestes,
which is like a media
and money conference,
and there's just deals, deals,
deals, deals everywhere.
Might have just touched
Bill Gates.
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
And all these massive mega deals
happen in these kind
of weird ski lodges.
So we always felt it would be
an interesting place
to set an episode.
Maybe we shouldn't
go with "ATN: We're Listening."
Oh, okay.
ARMSTRONG: Seeing Tom and Greg
down by the waterfall
and outside the movie theater
as they discuss
this unfortunate information
they find out about
what the company EPG
has been doing.
There's a grey area
in terms of our data collection,
so that we are kind of like--
We actually are listening.
You know I come from
a comedy-writing background
and there's something
very comfortable for me
about seeing two very able
comic performers do a bit.
-We're listening?
-Yeah.
But it's just to like maximize
the user experience.
But if that was to break,
maybe--
Oh, fuck!
The Roys are here.
Permission
to never fucking board?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
When a scandal hits,
you quickly take on
a different set of values
and a different perspective
which is able
to distance yourself
from the misdeeds itself.
It's cultural splash back.
We're being punished
for the sins of others.
Logan himself,
in the teeth of a proxy battle,
everyone has that straw
that breaks the camel's back...
You tortured the old dinosaur.
The tipping point.
ROMAN ROY:
You barbecued him live.
It's not like the most violent
attack in the world,
but there's something about
the suddenness and the ferocity,
and the surprise--
and I guess that
it's misdirected, you might say.
He was angry, not with Roman,
but with Shiv.
And the fact that Roman gets it
might be
an interesting observation
about the way anger
and frustration rebounds around
inside a family.
It's a tempest in a tea kettle.
Relax.
I drink them by the pint.
It's over.
LOGAN: Hey, hey,
I haven't finished!
ARMSTRONG:
I think in that moment,
you see Logan's fear.
At a certain point,
people walk away,
and that point, I guess,
is what's intriguing to us.
What is too much?
'Cause the world is tough
and the world is grubby,
and you end up having
to bend yourself
to people around you.
When do you decide
that you're bending too far,
and you're starting to corrupt
something inside?
It's an interesting question.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪